hello everyone and yes it is two more
days until the start of the candidates
tournament or rather until the opening
ceremony and three more days until the
actual first round and you guys have
requested that uh well maybe we should
show a game between the candidates or
maybe even better we should show a games
where the candidates have faced the
world champion magnus carlsen so this is
uh the first game in the series before
the start of the candidates uh it is
magnus carlsen with the white pieces
against hikaru nakamura the legendary
game from the 2016 bilbao masters it was
a double round robin and this is a game
from round one uh so uh the the the uh
tournament definitely starts with a bang
uh as this is uh hikaru's first uh oil
and the only win in classical chess
against magnus carlsen uh it is their
56th game altogether across all time
formats and uh well it's obviously a
very very special one and the story
about saying that in the previous video
okay on one part of the video i said
that the candidates was being played in
uh barcelona and the other one i said it
was played in madrid it's actually
played in madrid i have no idea why i
said barcelona
uh you know so sometimes my brain does
weird stuff
as i mentioned quite often uh but yeah
getting back to this game uh it is
magnus with the white pieces and he
opens with pawn to e4 and he carl plays
pawn to c5 the sicilian defense and this
is the like i said this is the 56th game
that they played all together and this
is the fifth time hikaru employs the
sicilian defense against magnus and
magnus doesn't go for the standard
knight f3 he goes for knight to e to the
so-called keras variation or sometimes
the chameleon variation
the
position can transpose into a normal
sicilian if white plays d4 but also
white doesn't have to play this so here
we have d6 by hikaru and now not d4 but
rather knight beat the c3 now we're
going to have g3 bishop to g2 and of
course magnus wolfie and keto the light
square bishop and castle king side so
pawn to a6 and now g3 we have g6 bishop
to g2 bishop to g7 and now magnus
strikes in the center with pawn to d4 we
have c counters on d4 knight captures on
d4 and knight to f6 now both players
castle so castles castles and now we
have pawn to b3 nowadays this is still
being played even though
but the engines say that you have to
play h3 here so h3 is the most popular
move uh but in 2016 uh pawn to b3 or
maybe it was even most popular uh
in 2016 to go h3 maybe b3 sort of a
surprise for hikar it's hard to say so
knight to c6 we have knight captures on
c6 b captures on c6 and now bishop to b2
so it was scary opening up the diagonal
like this but
everything works perfectly fine and now
queen to a5 sort of putting a lot of
pressure on this knight on c3 but it's
very hard to take advantage of this uh
just to give you a silly idea let's say
you play rook to e1
uh it seems like uh hikaru can just win
a pawn here knight captures an e4 and
you're upon because if knight captures
then we just capture the bishop and
we're just threatening to pick up a
piece here but you would be very very
wrong to do this because after rook
captures an e4 and bishop captures in c3
what is that one move that always wins
the game for white most of the time it
is of course pawn to b4 now you're
threatening to pick up the queen the
bishop the only way to prevent this is
bishop captures on b4 and now queen the
fourth threatening checkmate and winning
the piece and of course black would
resign here so but okay uh nothing like
this happens in the game it's just uh
you know for for some extra fun knight
to a4 and now uh if the knight moves we
can easily trade the bishops here and
bishop the g4 attacking carlson's queen
queen to e1 magnus offers a queen trade
and now queen to h5 hikaru declines
because why would you trade and allow
magnus to simply uh develop his rooks
for free so queen to h5 and now we have
pawn to f3 and this pawn to f3 i believe
is the start of uh
of uh white's downfall because even
though it's a it's a great move to play
it is it is much safer to just go
captures encounters and you know just
take the game from here uh
we trade the queens and that's it uh but
okay uh we have f3 challenging the
bishop now he carl plays bishop to h3
and now pawn to g4 now it seems like uh
it could get very ugly because if queen
h6 bishop to c1 but this is exactly what
hikaru does queen h6 and now even if
bishop c1 just g5 and uh it looks weird
but it works for black there's nothing
wrong with this so instead magnus first
plays bishop a to the
rook to d1 and now ponte g5 we have
bishop to c1 but it's hard to take
advantage of this so hikaru just plays
bishop captures king captures and queen
the g6 now getting the queen away from
this diagonal and now even uh
considering uh just busting open the
position with h5 so magnus does this
instead he plays h4 but before we check
out what actually happened in the game
uh let's see uh what happens if knight
to b6 because this is the uh real way to
play this position but it's such a weird
move to play for example if rook to
rocate to d8 or anywhere else uh we
re-maneuvered the knight to the c4 and
now after let's say h5 we play h3 that's
how you want to play this and now
you will have this maneuver of knight to
e3 to f5 which is just a beautiful
square for the knight the only way for
black to prevent this is to play e6 but
if you play e6 uh to take away the f5
square from the knight then you weaken
the d6 square so that's how white keeps
the edge in this position but okay
magnus played h4 right away uh g
captures an h4 queen captures an h4 and
now hikaru just
breaks three in the center with pawn to
d5 and now magnus has to decide does he
play e5 or does he play something else
because if you play e5 then you allow
queen captures on c2 with check but this
is again the absolute best way to play
this for example e5 knight to the d7 uh
attack the attacks the e5 pawn we're
going to play f4 and we have to allow
queen captures and c2 with check but
after rook d2 uh the queen will move
let's say queenie for checking the g1
the game continues uh and uh it's a fine
position for both white and black but
it's still the white king is uh
completely wide open uh white does have
the the incredible pressure here with
the pawns but still uh it's uh very very
difficult to actually play this yeah but
okay after d5 magnus plays g5 instead he
kicks away the knight this way but
hikaru doesn't have to move the knight
so this is uh
sort of a bit of an inferior move by
magnus so here d captures an e4 just
grabbing the pawn as of course uh the
the g pawn cannot move with f4 now
threatening f5 uh but uh he car just
plays e6 and there's a
no good way to play this with white
magnus now plays c4 he carl brings the
rook to the open d file rook f2d8 and
now we have rook d to e1
again we have to consider this knight to
b6 move but nothing
great is happening here because the
black can just straight for example
captures captures and play e3 now with
the thread of queen to c to check that's
the problem and now we would have
something like f5 queen captures now we
can pick up the knight still queen to c2
with check bishop d2 we're going to
capture the rook capture the pawn now
queen need to check bishop to f2 and
finally rook to d8 getting the rook
out of there and preparing rook to d2 or
maybe rook to d3 let's say if captures
on g7 rook d3 and yes it's a it's a
bishop and knight against the rook but
look at that white king there white is
not going to have any chances here
so instead after rook after d8 we have
rook d to e1
and now hikaru starts remaneuvering the
knight to f5 so he starts with knight to
e8 now knight to d6 the f5 will come and
uh well it's very very unpleasant when
you have uh king and g2 without any
pawns to defend the king and the knight
is uh approaching so knight to c5 this
is an excellent square for carlson's
knight as well as there is no b pawn or
d pawn to kick it away from there knight
to d6 and now we have queen back to f2
as the knight is coming to f5 you do not
want your queen here so queen to f2 uh
pawn to f5 by hikaru instead of knight
to f5 because if you go knight to f5 now
uh then the e4 pawn hangs so you can't
do this right away so instead of just on
the f5 and the knight will have to find
a different uh outpost but now black's
position is just uh is just great so
here we have uh bishop to b2
uh getting the the bishop to this
diagonal the counter he carves a strong
dark square bishop but here just knight
to f7
uh we have bishop captures and g7 queen
king captures the queen has to keep an
eye on the e6 pawn and now we have queen
to g3 so now rook to d6 you could also
play rook to d to check trade off a pair
of rooks and then bring the other rook
into the game but hikaru has a different
plan rook to d6 he wants to double rooks
and the d file roof to d1 we have rook 8
to d8 and now magnus trades once we have
captures captures and queen to c3 with
check king g8 now comes rook to f2
taking care of the second rank but now
queen to h5 this is how hikar
infiltrates you could also start with e5
right away but
there's no need to play fancy moves as
the position is just much better for
black queen to h5 and now we have queen
to h3 offering a queen trade but now
queen to d1 and now
at some point uh this e5 move will come
where we're gonna win the e5 square for
our knight and the position will slowly
but surely become uh on un unbearable
for white we have queen back to e3 now
comes pawn to e5 queen back to g3 now he
carl plays rook to g6 uh still keeping
an eye on the sixth string but
how how are you defending all of this so
king h2 uh magnus uh gets the king to a
bit of a safer square pawn captures on
f4 queen captures and now queen the h5
with check king g1 and now he cover
repeats once uh well probably to reach
time control is this is move 39 but also
maybe to just give magnus the
opportunity to make a mistake because he
can always just repeat position and then
choose something else so queen to d1
check king h2 and now he repeats because
if you play something else other than
king to h2 uh then you you're going to
run
in
in some trouble for example if you if
you lost on like queen to d4 putting
pressure on the knight and so on so okay
queen to h5 with check again we have
king to g1 and now just knight captures
on e5 opening up the g file and here
magnus finds a way to keep the knight at
bay so queen to b8 check king g7 queen
to e5 with check king to h6 and now
queen f4 not allowing the knight to move
uh but um it is simply not enough queen
to d1 with chuck king h2 now queen to d4
attacking the knight and there is no way
to
uh to defend here uh there is one tricky
a move for example queen h4 czech king
g7 and now queen captures and g5 saying
that if the queen is captured we have
this check winning back the queen the
problem is black of course is not forced
to capture the queen black can just pick
up your rook that's hanging on f2 and
after the king moves we just pick up the
queen and now of course white resigns so
hopefully you were not considering that
so here b4 uh why not that move has
never let us down uh king to g7 now we
have to unpin the knight and uh get our
king to safety the safety will be on h8
and we will block checks with rook to g8
so queen c7 check king the h8 queen the
c8 check king rook the g8 and the now
queen captures on f5 uh but now the game
is over it's a forced mate in six uh you
can start with knight to f3 or queen to
d6 both moves will lead to the same
thing knight to f3 with check king h3
and now of course queen to d6 this is
the quickest way to win the game you can
play any other move basically but queen
to d6 is just instant resign for magnus
so it was on this move uh in this
position on move 50 that magnus calls
and resigned to the game and hikaru gets
his first victory against the magnus
crossing in classical chess first and
only ever
uh and he starts the tournament with a
win as this is the uh the the first
round so incredible way to start the
tournament here you resign because
there's no defense this is checkmate and
this will be checkmate so whatever you
do uh there's just no way to defend both
the rook is completely cutting off the
king from the g file the knight
completely uh covering h4 and h2 so any
check will be uh game over so uh the
there is no way to play this it is uh
that's just game even even if you try
giving up some material we still just
play queen h6 check and that's it you
have to block with the queen this is
checkmate so
there's nothing you can even try here
uh so interestingly uh even though
hikaru got his win against magnus in
classical in round one so he definitely
started the tournament on a high note it
was magnus carlsen who won the
tournament because this was one of those
tournaments where you get uh three
points for a win that's how they played
it in bill wow in 2016 and as you can
see pretty much everyone uh just drew
their games anish geary zero wins uh
seven draws karjakin zero wins nine
draws away yi one win eight draws wesley
so one win eight draws he carved one win
this one against magnus and nine draws
but magnus four wins uh one lost that
one tahika that we've just shown and
only five draw so magnus wins this uh uh
by a five point mark a margin uh hikaru
clinching uh the third place then we
have wesley and the way he with eleven
sergey ferrari and anish with seven
points so that that is the story of how
magnus defeated uh of hakikara defeated
magnus in classical in 2016 in bilbao uh
it was a pretty wild game uh
many many uh you know opportunities
missed by both sides but
uh ones that uh
once magnus's king just was was
completely in the open and even though
you could actually play this position
maybe uh to a drawn it's just incredibly
difficult to do so with
such an open king
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it nowadays maybe people feel
more comfortable playing with an open
king as the engines really showed us the
way they say that it's perfectly fine
you have nothing to worry about you just
have to play the strongest move all the
time and you're going to be completely
fine but maybe in 2016 it was a a bit
too too much to ask uh so we'll see if
uh hikaru will bring his absolute best
classical stuff in the candidates
tournament uh you guys are also welcome
to suggest other games using hashtag
suggestion uh so uh you know we we can
cover some other games before the start
of the candidates uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys uh
enjoyed this one i really enjoyed
covering it uh i would like to thank
martin georg paparik god of mishra
michael colbert nagarjuna pongotti and
narendra yadala for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and uh
covering the uh games of the candidates
before the actual start of the
candidates on june 17th uh thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day